toujours concernant les états unis les
patients atteints du coït 19 ne sont pas
tous égaux face à la maladie dans
plusieurs régions du pays l'épidémie
semble frapper démesurément la
communauté afro-américaine de multiples
responsables réclament la publication de
statistiques nationales afin de
comprendre l'ampleur du phénomène selon
et bonnet hilton anesthésiste au centre
médical de l'université de virginie ce
n'est pas quelque chose de nouveau en
écoute
nous savons que les afro américains ont
moins de chance d'être testé moins de
chances d'être admis à l'hôpital moins
de ressources disponibles à grande
échelle
ce n'est pas quelque chose de nouveau et
donc lorsque vous avez une pénurie de
tests disponibles
alors ces populations ciblées vont
encore plus risqué d'être privé du même
accès aux soins que tout le monde
lorsque vous avez un système qui ne
soigne pas ces personnes de statut
social et économique plus bas et ses
minorités elles ne sont pas testés elles
sont renvoyées chez elles au sein de
leur communauté et ses travailleurs qui
sont maintenant infecté vont dans les
supermarchés et lorsque les couches
supérieures de l'amérique iront faire
leurs courses
elles seront elles aussi affectées